there's something i don't think we've
ever actually talked about on computer
file and it
is this the humble mouse
you've got disco mics they've got lights
on the bottom this is like a kind of
save yourself from repetitive strain
injury version and this is more classic
but probably not as classic as what
you're holding mine's from a rollerball
disco
the way to think about a mouse is to
break it down into
three chunks i mean there's the sensing
technology which you've got at the
bottom of the mouse
as you say detects the movement as you
move it around on the surface so you
need some sort of
technology to detect how the mouse is
moving
you've then got well effectively the
cable that comes out of the mouse you
need some way of sending that
information
from the mouse to the computer and then
you need to draw the actual
pointer on screen and then have it move
around now the pointer on screen that's
that's probably the simplest thing
you're going to get data from the mouse
telling it how it's moved and so you can
just update its location on screen and
redraw it
we won't consider in that's more of a
graphics problem you do the same thing
to draw sprites in a game or any sort of
movement of something within the screen
so we'll ignore that for now what we'll
concentrate on is
how do we sense the mouse's movement and
then how do we actually send
the data over the cable to the computer
or i guess these days over bluetooth or
some sort of wireless link to the
computer
what i thought we'd also do is it's
probably easiest to start
at the beginning so we'll start by
looking at a rollerball mouse and see
how that worked
and then we'll sort of take the
discussion up and look at how the
optical mice we have today work
and also how the optical mice that were
sort of existed in the past also worked
as well because
optical mice as we know today appeared
around 2000 around the turn of the
millennium
but there were optical mice all the way
through the 80s and 90s as well but they
required special mouse mats that they
had to run on
if you didn't have one of them then your
mouse wouldn't work
because if you've got a modern optical
mice if you try and run it on a shiny
surface and you may well have exactly
the same problem with certain
implementations so
they all sort of have their limitations
of technology so let's start with this
one what we end up having in the mouse
is a little steel ball with a rubber
coating on it and that sort of
moves as you press the mouse moves
around on the surface of inside the
mouse
you've got two rollers or three rollers
but two rollers
which are touching the ball and as it
moves it causes those rollers to move so
let's just take the mouse apart try not
to lose any bits
i'm not too worried about this one
because this one has an interesting
thing up and down works fine
horizontal motion works fine going in
one direction and if you push it in the
other direction it
still goes in the same direction which
is quite odd but we can talk about why
that might be the case
when we come to understand how this sort
of mouse works so let me just undo the
screw
what you used to have to do occasionally
was clear all the fluff out of it of
course because you'd have
yeah the mechanics would get gummed up
and
that wasn't the pleasant thing but it
was quite satisfying when you've done it
yeah
so exactly we can have a look at how
that would happen as well so inside the
mouse this is an atari st
or an amiga mouse depending on which way
the switch here is set i've got it set
for the atari st of course
we've got one ic on the mouse's circuit
but all that's doing is just taking the
signals from the rest of the circuit
and sort of conditioning them so that
when we send them over the cable they're
nice
clear digital signals with no sort of
bounces or anything on them
and so then what we have is we have this
arrangement here we've got these two
rollers that we said let me just
deconstruct this mouse a bit further and
we'll get to see all the fluff
there we go so we can get that bit out
so this is the bit that gets in contact
with the mouse balls we've got these two
things and you should be able to see
that there are two wheels here that turn
in relation as i move the ball so as we
move the ball
it's in contact with these rollers and
so these wheels
turn so that's why this one isn't
actually working because as we turn it
in one direction
the wheel turns as we turn it in the
other the wheels not turning at all so i
can fix that later
so the ball is in contact with two
rollers and as the ball moves it makes
these uh
discs move now these discs are
interesting because they are
have a sort of serrated edge and they've
got a sort of
hook like structure if i use the ipad i
can sort of
draw a diagram of what that would look
like so you've got this sort of
lightning bolt type shape
in there and so that's what's on the
edge of the disc and the reason why
you've got that
is because as these rotate they pass
between
a couple of sensors and these are
lightweight diode which probably gives
off something like infrared light
there's no need for it to be anything
else but it's all enclosed and then
you've got a photo transistor or a
couple of photo transistors so as this
wheel
just sort of spins that shape breaks the
light signal so you'll get a signal
being generated which will be on
off on off on off on off and that
movement will be in sympathy to the way
that the mouse ball is turning so as you
turn the ball faster
those things will that signal will
change fast dirty turn it slow it will
change
slower so we can work out how fast the
mouse
is moving by counting those pulses if i
draw a
diagram again we can see the sort of
signal we'll get so it'll start off
when the thing's blocked as being zero
volts because there's no light going
through
and then as the light comes through
it'll become one
and then as it changes it'll become zero
again and it'll become one then it'll
become zero again
and you'll get what there's a sort of
pulses of signals and if you count those
pulses you know how far the mouse is
moved
and the sort of rate at which that
changes tells you how fast the mouse is
moving
and so you can take that data send it to
the computer
and then you can move the pointer on
screen in sympathy to what's happening
you're getting a
signal telling you how fast it's moving
and you know whether that's along the
horizontal or along the vertical based
on which of the
rotating discs it is that you've got
there we've got two of them one for
vertical one for horizontal so we can
get how fast it's moving
but we also need to know which direction
it's moving and that's why we had that
sort of lightning sort of shape
in there because actually what happens
is we don't have one sensor
we actually have two and they're sort of
stacked vertically on top of each other
and because we've got that sort of
lightning shape
with that second sensor the signal is
delayed slightly so we've got this first
signal here
but the second sensor would be sort of
delayed
by a certain amount so actually the
pulses would change
delayed compared to the other one as
hopefully you can see in the diagram i'm
drawing very badly here
and so on so you'd have two sets of
pulses one delayed from the other
it's what we call quadrature encoding we
can actually derive from that
which direction the signal is moving in
so the speed of those pulses tell us the
rate
we know which direction it is because we
know which roller it's coming from and
we can look at those pulses and if the
pulse appears on the first sensor first
then we know it's moving in one
direction but if it appears on the
second sensor first we know it's moving
in the other direction
so by comparing the two pulse trains
because they are offset from each other
we can
also work out which direction the mouse
is moving in
so the first part of our problem can be
solved with this sort of arrangement
we can work out which direction the
mouse is in because we've got the two
pull strains and we can compare them
and see which one of them the pulses
arrive first on
the rate of the pulses tell us how fast
it is and we know whether it's up or
down or left or right
based on which of the sensors in our
mouse is actually
detecting the movement and they can both
detect at the same time which gives us a
sort of diagonal movement
and because the ray can change between
moving faster slowly we can not just
draw
straight diagonal lines we can do curves
and things as we move the mouse around
now if we go back to these discs again
if we look at them
they're quite closely spaced together
and the closeness of the spacing
would determine the resolution of the
mouse if you had smaller gaps
your pulses would appear quicker because
it would rotate at the same speed so
you'd have more
transitions for the same movement and so
you'd be able to move the mouse less to
move more distance on screen
conversely if you had larger gaps
between the
sections of the disc you'd end up having
to move it further to move the same
distance on screen so the sort of
resolution of the mouse that you got
depended on the sort of
discs that were had that span between
those sensors
so they their sort of original
rollerball mouse were quite simple you
had these sensors that detect the
movement
in the way you sent you've got some
simple electronics to sort of clean up
that signal
to get a nice digital signal which you
could then send up to the computer
over the cable we come to the second
thing which is how do we actually send
that data
to the computer so that we can deal with
it now with some of the original
computers things like the original
macintosh the original atari st
and the amiga for example you literally
just sent those pulse trains
up the cable into the computer and the
computer the software or hardware inside
the computer
decoded those signals it's relatively
straightforward as we said just to
detect which one of them
which one of the signals the pulses are
appearing on first and you can then work
out how the mouse is moving at the speed
the direction and so on
and then transmit it so for a lot of
mice they literally just send those
quadrature signals
straight up the cable into the computer
and let the computer
deal with it but that's not the case
with the ibm pc when the ibm pc was
originally designed
you didn't have a mouse port on it the
macintosh the amiga the atari st were
all designed to support graphical user
interfaces
they were all designed with a mouse
interface in there and so you could just
send those signals
but the ibm pc wasn't at the time it was
designed
ibm thought it would just have a command
line interface and so when you want to
introduce a mouse you had to sort of
introduce it using the ports that are
already available on there
and so what they did was that they used
the serial port
the serial port allowed you to send data
in the serial form to the computer
so they just co-opted one of the serial
ports to receive the data from the mouse
so but that means we need to format the
data from the mouse
not just in the sort of pulse trains
that are coming from the rollers and
things
but we actually need to convert it into
data that we can send in a serial form
so what happened with the original ibm
mice and then ps2 mouse did something
very very similar
the same thing happened with apple
desktop bus where mice were connected on
that
and of course with usb now what happens
is that now rather than trying to work
out
from the sort of pulse trains what's
happening inside the computer
inside the mouse you had a slightly more
complicated circuit which would decode
those quadrature encoded signals into
the direction and the velocity which the
mouse was moving
and it would then convert that into a
series of three bytes on the original
ibm mice
that were sent over the serial port to
the computer that it could then decode
to tell it how it was moving
and so those three bytes the first one
would tell you which of the buttons were
pressed the buttons are dead simple
they're literally just switches they're
open or closed
to send the data tell you which ones are
open or closed and it would also tell
you the direction
between whether it was moving up or down
or not or left or right
or not and then you would send you the
velocity of
it was moving along the x direction and
the velocity was moving along the y
direction
as i would constantly send that data
those three bytes continuously
after each other so that the computer
could receive the information about how
the mouse was moving so whereas the
original mice were sort of taking the
data and
offloading it to the computer to sort of
process and get the information
on the pc and the mice we have today the
processing is done
inside the mouse and the pc the computer
is just receiving the data
that it can then use to update the
position of the pointer
on the screen are these disco mice the
same
actually this one's not even plugged in
so you're getting no red light from that
let's try that with one that is
are these uh flashy mouse mice
do they work the same apart from the
mechanics how does the optical bit work
that's a good question an optical master
probably been around longer than most
people realize
there were optical mice in the 80s and
90s particularly on sun workstations
but these use a slightly different
technology you had to have a special
mouse pad for them which had
a grid of dots printed on it and as you
move the mouse over there
that grid of dots would have had the
same sort of effect as the sort of
spinning wheel and created the pulse
trains so you've been able to track it
what i think you're talking about is a
sort of modern sort of optical mice i've
got one here
where you've got a sort of red light
shining at the bottom of it and if you
look you can just see there's a sort of
very tiny camera sensor in the bottom of
there as well
these work in a very different way but
if we think about if we backtrack from
what we need the computer to receive we
can start to understand how they might
work
there's literally a little camera
photographing several thousand times a
second the desk or however fast the
camera's refreshing
and then as you move the mouse the image
will change and then it's doing a
comparison of the two images to sort of
work out how they've been shifted the
same sort of comparison you would do
in a video compression algorithm to work
out how to move one bit to another
and once you know how far you have to
move the image from the previous frame
that you took to the next frame
you know how the mouse has moved and so
you can send that data
to the computer now the problem you need
to do there is you need to sort of get a
really good image
of the actual desk so that you can sort
of see the structure of it so you can
actually
track things moving about and the way
that they do that if i use my phone
as an example here the light is sort of
shining
across the desk so it highlights all the
sort of pits and troughs
of the desk and so you can see the
structure of it which is why it doesn't
work so well
if you have a very very flat or smooth
surface because it's not highlighting
anything and of course glass it would
just shine straight through
and so the mouse wouldn't work at all so
you end up using to use some sort of
lasers to try and get the same effect
but what you're basically doing is
you've got a camera pointing down at the
desk you've lit it and you've
illuminated it in such a way
that you can actually really see the
structure so as it moves you can see how
things are moving around
and then you're just comparing the
images to see just how much the image
has moved
and so you can get that data and send it
to the computer and the mouse pointer
would then move
in the same way this sort of technique
was developed by hp and the sort of
microsoft were the first people to
release a mouse that used this
technology
um in the very early 2000s i think it's
around 2002 i first got one that worked
in this sort of fashion
and so on and so it was much smoother
you didn't have to clear your you roll
the ball out
um when it got all sort of lint and
things you didn't get fluff around the
rollers
you had to clean out and things so it's
much better it's much better at tracking
things you didn't get quite scenario so
many errors as you move the mouse around
and so it's a much better experience for
sort of moving your mouse and sort of
keeping things going
so yeah definite improvement on the old
rollerball
sort of technology that you get
blue has also got cheaper paths
now i think you or i can see
looking at that but we've now got the
cheapest cost passed for everything
so yeah they're very different to the
originals and the important thing is
that
we don't know what went into here right
we know